hello how are you greets I left Jaramillo
with the brief information for today Monday
June 14 several
vaccination clinics continue to operate around the
valley for this week on Tuesday and
Wednesday one will be held at the
fire station near Durango
ITD Holstein on Thursday for
Vaccines will be administered in the morning at Parque de
Querer y Cipher near Mojave and
Washington and on Saturday it will take place
inside the Yubero Retiree Center
located on Jay streets near the
late-night billboard. No appointment needed.
Vaccines will be administered by
order of  arrival
the fire has been released and is
90 percent contained this
is about 10 miles southwest
of las vegas crews reveal they
worked to control it as it
destroyed more than 1,300 acres they estimate it
will have 100 percent control for
on thursday this fire started on
thursday afternoon
station casinos offers job fairs
to settle the demand mi  As
the city recovers from the crisis
caused by the pandemic, the first one
will be tomorrow at the butter station from 8 in
the morning to 7 in the afternoon. On Wednesday
there will be another job fair at
Bareback and on Thursday it will be at Green Bay
Lunch for  For more details on how to fill out
the application, among other information,
visit our page at disney.com
diagonal in Spanish
Now we turn to the weather forecast
This week we will have temperatures
exceeding 100 degrees We will be on
an extreme heat alert We remind you to
stay hydrated and avoid being
exposed to the sun  for several hours the
temperatures will increase reaching
the beautiful weekend on Monday rosso and
it will move away from me and this was his brief
informative of illusion in Spanish
[Music]